ich glaube ich bin echt brunnen hohen
zahlen ist es glaube ich nicht
aufgefallen war eine lange zeit dachte
ich dass diese beiden youtuber von der
plattform verschwunden sind sie haben
lange zeit nichts hochgeladen sie waren
inaktiv und youtube community hat licht
am ende des tunnels gesehen es ist die
rede von leona und simon desue doch die
beiden sind zurück meine damen und
herren
siral landen radeln wahrscheinlich
radeln so oder die beiden sind wieder
aktiv auf youtube haben in letzter zeit
wieder einige videos hochgeladen und ein
video hat mich ein wenig getriggert 24
stunden im solarium extrem verbrannt ich
habe das nicht einfach mal runtergeladen
hast du die besten szenen sage ich mal
mir ausgeprägt und die schauen wir uns
jetzt mal zusammenhang
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja
ich habe nicht den ton aus feldern
lassen das haben die wirklich im schnitt
vergessen also die stimme sagt einfach
warnung bitte nicht nachmachen diese
zwei vollidioten
mehr nicht aber zum glück ist noch etwas
eingeblendet und zwar diese zwei
vollidioten sind professionelle
stuntmans
stand man's man's seid ihr dumm alter
der plural von ben also einem mann im
englischen ist men
laut euch würde die serie two and a half
men dann touren der haffmans heißen
als ich das gesehen habe dachte ich mir
schon viel schlimmer kann es eigentlich
nicht werden aber doch also wir haben
doch gar nicht einfach das video als ich
reg mich schon auf das gefühl ich muss
wieder le mans start heute wieder zu
einem fläschen view bisher als noch
alles vollkommen in ordnung und ich habe
mir natürlich was richtig geil ist
überlegt natürlich nicht mit diesem
typen mit bösen
natürlich nicht mit diesen typen
also deutsch ist definitiv nicht da an
der stelle muss ich allerdings ganz gut
sagen freunde wie es bei jeder reaktion
natürlich sage ich habe nichts gegen sei
mit und leandra persönlich ich habe mich
noch nie so richtig mit denen wir live
unterhalten ich kenne die beiden nicht
persönlich deswegen es kann sein dass
die beiden mega chillige typen sind und
wie die allerbesten freunde werden ich
bezweifle es war aber man hat zumindest
gehört dass es nichts gegen die beiden
persönlich ist ein sondern nur gegen
diese seine video
ganz kurze information nach jeder szene
die ich mir ausgesucht habe sitze ich
hier einfach so
das ist doch so krank wind da stehen
zwei erwachsene männer und meine damen
und herren die sind beide 26 also die
gehen sie langsam auf die 30 zu also da
stehen zwei erwachsene männer vor einem
supermarkt und dämme und schreien dumm
rum und dann kommt noch eine oma im
hintergrund her gelaufen was sie sich
denn gedacht haben
aber ich will gar nicht so viel aber wir
schauen uns jetzt mal mehr das video an
ok stunden 24 stunden im solarium
einerseits ist der 24 stunden trends ek
ein jahr alt und andererseits ist man
dann tot oder hat zumindest hautkrebs
und by the way und das ist ja eine mega
innovative idee ich weiß gar nicht wo du
die eventuell her haben könntest dich an
der stelle muss ich wirklich jetzt mal
etwas sagen was ich so glaube ich noch
nie gesagt habe es heimen du hast recht
zwei erwachsene männer gehen in einen
supermarkt und der eine fragt für den
anderen ob er dort ein praktikum machen
kann
das ist einfach herablassen den
mitarbeitern dort gegenüber weil man
merkt wie ihr euch darüber lustig macht
beiden sind jetzt auf jeden fall im
supermarkt und kaufen dort lebensmittel
und gegenstände einen die man bei einer
24 stunden im solarium challenge zu
brauchen ein normaler mensch würde da
als an beispielsweise sonnencreme denken
oder ganz viel wasser weil die haut
austrocknen oder beispielsweise decke so
dass man nicht verbrennt leon und heimen
sehen das ein bisschen anders einfach
ein solarium
smarties eis ich habe wieder meine
standard haltung eingenommen schreibt
mir die kommentare mögt ihr schokolade
nein das war jetzt keine bescheuerte
sehen oder lustig dummes 10 auf die ich
hier reagieren wollte die ist deswegen
raus geschnitten habe aber streamen
ich sympathisiere ein bisschen mit dir
ich hasse auch schokoladen eis und
schweinen sind jetzt auf jeden fall
fertig mit ihrem supermarkt einkauf und
bewegen sich nun die innenstadt zu dem
solarium studio wo die er die challenge
umsetzen wollen kissen ich würde sagen
michael otto und verzichten die letzten
werden die ich bereits vorhin gesagt
habe ein normaler mensch würde sich
eventuell noch so eine challenge jetzt
so vorbereiten dass es schon mal mit der
sonnencreme ein trend oder vorher ganz
ganz viel wasser ex oder vorher ein
bisschen schläft oder keine ahnung was
leon und salmen ziehen sich einfach ich
sag mal passende outfits an bauer war
sehr geil fastenbrechen hier drin eins
muss ich euch beiden lassen
richtig hirzel in der haard unterhaltsam
nun sind die beiden aber auf jeden fall
im solarium angekommen haben sich dort
mit der frau abgesprochen und haben eine
kabine zugeteilt bekommen der sie sich
freuen lassen können und jetzt hat leon
eine entscheidende frage an seinen
konzern
wer ist wer sitzt jetzt wo also das ist
eine liege im solarium und ich weiß
nicht wie ihr beiden diese 24 stunden
challenge machen wollt aber ich glaube
nicht dass ihr euch beide in diese liga
einsetzen können manchmal wie schlecht
die ideale und manchmal hast du wirklich
dumme ideen du jetzt machen die zwei
noch ein bisschen schwach sind in diesem
solarium studio sage ich mal in ihrer
kabine und entdecken die uv brillen und
das finden die mega cool das ist kein
hashtags anlasses geld
das ist echt einfach nur fremdschämen
und man denkt sich an sondern stelle ja
da sind zwei vollidioten die machen die
24 jahre im schönen stoffen erst um
durch den supermarkt machen dann
irgendwie dumm was mit den sonnenbrillen
dort einmal pöbeln leute irgendwie blöd
an und jetzt tanzen könnt ihr mir sagen
welcher youtuber noch nicht
eine vollzeit dance challenge
hochgeladen hat es eigentlich ist es
eine schande dass ich das noch nicht
gemacht habe aber seinen übernimmt da
meinen job
doch nun meine damen und herren bewegen
sich die beide youtuber in die wiege und
wie sie ein normaler mensch machen würde
und sich komplett ausziehen würde um
sich komplett räumen zu lassen
naja die beiden haben das nicht so ganz
verstanden
beide lange hose weil dennoch irgendwie
t shirt und wenn ich sogar ein pulli an
und natürlich ihre mützen
ja
das ist so das ist eine kranke
vorstellung irgendwie wirklich zwei
erwachsene männer gehen zusammen ins
solarium legen sich zusammen dort völlig
angezogen hin mit smarties eis und aber
wie wir schon mal weiter per turbo zu
kommen die ganzen vorschläge
die beiden haben jetzt also die liege
zugemacht und befinden sich jetzt zu
zweit in dieser sonnenliege und jetzt
sehen wir auch die tollen ton
verhältnisse darin klasse ton leon ja
also ich will jetzt kein tipp geben oder
so leon aber ich würde ihm 400 eine t
shirt und pulli auszuziehen
das ist es vielleicht doch nicht so
heißt eine halbe minute nächste ich
schwitze für das tut ist mir ehrlich
gesagt ist er freunde leon ist ein
mensch er schreibt in den titel 24
stunden im solarium oder nach einer
halben minute
das sind nicht einmal 0,1 prozent der
kompletten zeit die er da drin sein will
meckert herum dass ihm zu heiß ist das
eben dass er schweizer team schwindelig
ist das stimmt oder sieben stunden wird
schlecht ich jetzt wird dem auch noch
schlecht
dass ich jetzt denkt ja auch noch daran
dass herr umkippen kann
du liegst auf einer liege da kannst du
höchst es bewusstlos werden aber du
kannst ja nicht umkippen
nun passiert etwas sehr interessantes
und symbolisches für erlernbar chefs 24
stunden videos und zwar lügen er sagt
sie sind jetzt schon elf minuten dort
drin
[Musik]
wir suchen viel zu unsicher
habt ihr einmal die komplette uhr
eingeblendet gesehen
nein
ich auch nicht
denn er hat sie nicht eingeblendet leon
hat extra mit dem handy so gefilmt dass
man nur diese kunden und die letzte
minute sieht also wahrscheinlich waren
sie einfach eineinhalb minuten
bisherigen aber na gut bis die ersten
großen plan würde ich weiß nicht wo ich
bei diesem ausschnitt anfangen soll zwei
erwachsene männer liegen zusammen auf
einer liege im solarium der eine für den
anderen mit center schock mit center
schock beiden haben ein smarties eis auf
der stirn liegen damit ihnen nicht so
heiß es aber trotzdem haben sie
unfassbar viele klamotten noch an und
dann sagt seine noch hält ist die beste
medizin wissen
ich lass das einfach mal so stehen 14
minuten um 9
und auch in diesem tag sehen wir nicht
die uhr eingeblendet doch nun meine
damen und herren kommen wir hier
wirklich jetzt zu einem punkt des videos
so etwas passiert mit dem man vorher
glaube ich nicht rechnen konnte leon
masch er stellt sich tot
und jetzt sehen wir schauspielkunst auf
einem level was die welt noch nicht
gesehen hat
[Musik]
das stift gar nicht im regal denker komm
raus war viel zu lange wurde das für
viele stunden an der stelle habe ich mir
wirklich ein wenig sorgen um den lieben
leben schwer gemacht
ich dachte hey nach so keine ahnung
runtergebrochen vielleicht sieben
minuten im solarium kann man schon mal
ja es war ein franken
[Applaus]
deshalb aller zeiten sowie haben gerade
nicht gefilmt die sonnenbank ausgang ist
aber dieses eine mal wieder sieht man
auch in dieser einstellung nicht die
zeit eingeblendet doch nun fällt leon
etwas atemberaubendes auf musst du das
ding ist glaube ich bin echt brunnen
leon masche realisiert dass er im
solarium braun geworden ist
heimann ist es glaube ich nicht
aufgefallen beide sind jetzt auf jeden
fall von der liege wieder aufgestanden
und fassen das ganze jetzt noch mal kurz
zusammen
das was mit dem video würde ich sagen
seid herzlich grüße und billig 24
stunden bis zum harz hat ein bisschen
abwarten
durchziehen können was er sagt dann
nochmal hey seid uns nicht böse dass
wenn ich die rund 20 stunde durchgezogen
haben habt ein bisschen erbarmen wieso
sollen wir erbarmen haben wir haben euch
doch nicht dazu gezwungen und du hast in
den titel geschrieben 24 stunden im
solarium extrem verbrannt wo habt ihr
euch eigentlich extrem verbrannt und wo
wart ihr 24 stunden im solarium der
komplette titel ist irreführend die tags
will ich mir gar nicht erst anschauen
was ich einfach nur so krass finden der
unser schicksal des trio ist dass das
mittlerweile gar keiner mehr infrage
stellt
die machen einfach die lügen ihre
communitys an und ist juckt einfach kein
weil es einfach standard geworden ist
was ich den zweiten aber auf jeden fall
gut heißen muss es ihr seid echt krass
unterhaltsam und ihr habt echt überhaupt
kein schamgefühl also einfach so im
supermarkt rumzulaufen und irgendwie
leuten eben den scheiß zu erzählen sonst
finde ich sehr sehr unterhaltsam aber
ich selbst würde es nie machen und
irgendwie es auch ein bisschen
respektlos aber leere zeilen was ich mir
bei euch mega gut vorstellen könnte wer
soll straßen format irgendwie einfach
durch die straßen läuft irgendwie
entweder leute verarscht bei denen
fragen stellt oder keine ahnung was das
fänd ich mega cool und ganz im ernst ich
glaube das könnte bei euch richtig gut
ankommen und die könnte das richtig gut
umsetzen also um jetzt wirklich noch so
ein bisschen was konstruktives mit rein
gebracht zu haben
aber freunde an der stelle würde ich
sonst auch direkt auf das video beenden
ich habe jetzt diesmal nicht live drauf
reagiert sondern mir das video vorher
schon angeguckt ein paar szenen
rausgeschnitten weil das video ging 12
minuten und da wären mein reschen eine
halbe stunde lang geworden weil es euch
das video hier gefallen hat das gerne
mal ein leichter freunde schaffen wir
60.000 likes
der mega cool schreibt man in die
kommentare
solarium falls ihr noch dran seid falls
ja schon lange das video und ihr könnt
mir auch mal einen kommentar schreiben
coface sich auch demnächst mal reagieren
soll